this is what the Indian government
wanted to prevent hundreds of people
crowding together migrant workers in the
state of Bihar filled overcrowded buses
some even climbed on the roofs in a
desperate attempt to return to their
homes so he saw this bus and came and
sat here and taught that the driver must
be somewhere but no one was here
authorities are saying that the bus will
go but how will we go we just keep
waiting migrant workers around the
country tried to catch buses after
Indian Railways canceled train services
which carry more than 25 million
commuters a day all interstate buses and
Metro services are also canceled until
the end of the month the Ministry of
Civil Aviation announced all domestic
flights will be suspended from Wednesday
Prime Minister Narendra Modi tweeted
saying many people are still not taking
the lockdown seriously even though most
public places were deserted around the
country many regional leaders including
in the Capital Territory of Delhi said
they would take action against anyone
who violates the measures now everyone
from today has to obey the lock down
completely then lockdown started this
morning maybe you had to go out for some
necessary work but from tomorrow the
government will enforce the lockdown and
we will use force to ensure it Arvind
Kejriwal also announced financial and
humanitarian assistance to those
affected in Delhi as the Indian
government introduces more restrictions
every day to limit the spread of the
virus many who've lost their livelihoods
or have been stranded are also hoping to
hear how the government will help them
beyond telling them to stay at home
Elisabeth puranam al-jazeera New Delhi